going to be food and booths outside and
not lose thanks Dave um so in this talk
I'm going to describe some of the work
that my group's been doing on developing
stochastic gradient MCMC methods both
from independent iid and dependent data
sources in various parts of this talk
our joint work with my students en la
tra Chad and Jack Baker and my postdoc
big phony okay so one of the big
emphases in my group is looking at time
series applications and they tend to be
high dimensional complex processes that
we're observing and trying to analyze
one example of this is a collaboration
we've had with Zillow for some years so
where the goal is to model a local level
housing index so from historical house
sales observations we want to estimate
the value at a very local level and how
that value changes over time in this
application one thing that we've shown
is really important is to discover
regions that behave similarly over time
and use that to share information
between these regions and improve local
estimates so here's a city of Seattle
analysis where each one of these colors
if it's the same color across regions
that means those regions were discovered
to behave similarly and for each one of
these different clusters of regions
here's the latent value in that region
averaged across these these different
regions over time um another set of
applications that we focus on quite
heavily is neuroimaging data sets so for
example an M EG % sits in this chair and
wears this helmet with all these
spatially distributed sensors that
provide recordings of underlying brain
activity and this data provides this
really high-resolution neural imaging
data set with very good time resolution
and a question here might be 10 for
something like functional connectivity
networks which are statements of which
regions in the brain work together in
response to a given stimuli another data
source that we've looked at is
intracranial EEG and I'll skip over the
gory picture but the point is that not
only do you have a single channel of
activity but you have a large collection
of different channels and there's really
interred
relationships in how these things evolve
over time so maybe from this data we
might be interested in automatically
parsing these types of recordings into
interprete below a neurologist to study
and start analyzing what type of
seizures are present in a given
patient's recordings or maybe algorithms
could do this automatically but this
little snippet of data that I showed is
just one little episode within a very
long recording and there are many
episodes of interest
these recordings are sometimes on the
order of two weeks long okay so in
general when we're thinking about
analyzing these types of high
dimensional large complex time series we
often end up taking not always but often
end up taking a Bayesian modeling
approach in theory it can be really nice
for discovering shared structure and
modeling intricate relationships but
that's really in theory in practice you
often end up hitting up against a lot of
the Bayesian inference issues that we've
heard today so another big push in my
group has been on developing scalable
Bayesian inference techniques along the
lines of things that all the David's
have talked about today um unfortunately
my name is not David so changing it a
bit here but um we're going to focus in
specifically on MCMC and think about how
we target these complex posteriors
arising from these complex models
intricate data sources especially in
these large data settings okay so more
specifically we're going to write our
posterior as PI and it says prior
proportional type to prior times
likelihood and so one of the challenges
we're talking about is the fact that the
structure of our posterior might be
really complex so some examples of
complex features of posterior might be
being very multi multi modal or having
strong correlations across dimensions
and these types of structures pose
challenges to traditional sampling based
methods very hard to mix between these
modes or really explore these different
contours
so this is an issue of efficiency of the
sampler David was referring to this as
you know having to do with mixing rates
of these samplers but another challenge
is the fact that we might just have lots
and lots of observations that we're
conditioning on so we want to
incorporate all these observations in
drawing our inferences and how do we do
this efficiently so a very standard
example these days thanks to David and
his followings are just looking at
document analysis and having tons and
tons of documents that you want to parse
through so we'll come back to Wikipedia
Korkis analysis later but this is an
issue of scalability this per iteration
complexity of doing sampling okay so
what's a classic approach to doing MCMC
well typically people look at jump
processes and one very standard approach
is the metropolis Hastings algorithm
where you define a kernel that depends
on your past sample value and you use
that to propose your next value and then
you either accept or reject this
proposal so this is an example of a jump
process you're just going to be jumping
around this space and often it's really
hard to move between low probability
regions and it really inefficiently
explores this posterior okay
so instead over the last five plus years
there's been growing interest in what
I'll call continuous dynamic based
samplers or gradient MCMC and these are
methods at a very high level that define
either stochastic or deterministic
dynamics to explore some energy
landscape I'll explain what this energy
landscape represents some how it's
related to this target posterior you're
interested in and by using these
dynamics you're able to simulate these
very dissonant proposals okay so one
popular example of such a continuous
dynamic sampler is a Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo or HMC so this is the same target
distribution we looked at before but
here we're going to write it as
the exponentiation of a negative
potential energy where in the case of
Bayesian inference this potential energy
is just log-likelihood times prior and
for all these continuous dynamic based
samplers I want to mention we're going
to be focusing on the parameter is
living in R to the D okay okay so
continuous parameters face well in HM C
what we do is we augment this
distribution of interest with an
auxilary variable R which is going to
represent momentum in some physical
system and then jointly these two terms
are going to define this energy
landscape that we're going to be
exploring so in particular we now have a
joint distribution over theta our
parameters of interest and this
auxiliary variable R and we write this
as the potential energy plus this
kinetic energy term thinking of our is
momentum so the sum of these two terms
is called the Hamiltonian or total
energy okay so now that we've defined
what this energy landscape is what HMC
does is it uses Hamiltonian dynamics to
explore these this landscape and in
particular what Hamiltonian dynamics
will do is for walk around a given level
set of this landscape so and we're going
to specifically be collecting samples at
some fixed time interval as we're
walking around this level set so more
formally you can write down Hamiltonian
dynamics as follows and there's this
nice analogy with playing ice hockey
that's due to Radford Neil we're here
there's a puck has position theta has
some mass and it has momentum and you're
playing on this frictionless ice surface
but the surface isn't flat it's really a
hilly surface so this is really what
you're playing on and the gradient of
your potential energy is defining the
slope of this surface at any point theta
in in your arm in the space okay so
because this puck has momentum this is
what's going to help us simulate these
distant proposals and one of the really
key
things about hamiltonian dynamics is the
fact that they leave your target
distribution invariant um yeah so there
are you listed in the are equal to zero
and the rest of it is to make it more
efficient or so are equal to zero so I'm
going to describe that on the next slide
so we're interested in adding this R to
give us this momentum the to these
dynamics and we're going to simulate
jointly theta an to R so to get or get
this T so far we've just talked about
for basically a fixed value of R walking
around a level set but to get or go to
city which you need in order to ensure
that your simulated samples or samples
from the desired target distribution HM
Siri samples this momentum variable so
you can be jumping between these level
sets and then walking around them and
then if you just want samples of theta
that was our original goal what you do
well if you're familiar with MC MC you
just discard your samples of our and
you're going to get samples from the
desired target distribution just on
theta
okay so hm C represents one possible set
of dynamics that we can use to get these
types of explorations of these energy
landscapes or equivalently target
posteriors and what we said is we want
PI to be invariant under our specified
dynamics so that if we also have our go
DISA T then the simulated samples are
samples from the desired posterior but
there lots of other dynamics that we
could specify and a question is out of
all these possible dynamics which ones
have this property of having the right
stationary distribution so out of all
possible continuous Markov processes
which you can equate with these defining
these either these different continuous
dynamics only a subset will leave PI
invariant so we said hm C has that
property so do so does the simpler
Lanterman baseline dynamics and they're
also dynamics that you can define which
are just remount variants of these
algorithms that also have the right
stationary distribution
but the natural question is is there a
general recipe for constructing such a
dynamic that will live in this space so
for constructing a sampler that has the
right target distribution assets
stationary distribution
well my student Yama had this really
nice insight that it is possible to do
this so in particular we're going to
think of having this posterior on some
set of variables Z which are going to
represent both our parameters of
interest as well as some potential
auxilary variables like this momentum
variable and we're going to write just
like an H MC and in terms of this total
energy or this energy landscape H and
what the the formula is is G and define
this stochastic differential equation
that's solely specified in terms of a
positive semi-definite matrix D a skew
symmetric matrix Q and then you pass in
the form of this total energy and if you
simulate from this SDE then you're doing
the right thing so these dynamics leave
PI as the invariant distribution okay so
if you want to know what SD looks like
it looks like the following you don't
need to digest this to understand the
rest of this talk but H is our total
energy and W is a d-dimensional Wiener
process yeah so that's a question I'll
come back to you after is that ok can I
return to that question so the so this
is a framework there's multiple points
to this framework and maybe I'll
highlight that as I'm going through if
that's okay so one is showing that if
you're sick if your dynamics have this
form you know you're doing the right
thing
so if you can cast your dynamics in this
form you're doing the right thing you
can also use it to propose new samplers
by looking at news and new design cues
okay so what we showed is that if you
use this ste for any positive
semi-definite D and skew-symmetric Q
then you're in this right part of this
space and one of the cool things is all
these Sam
that I mentioned before you can actually
cast in this framework so you can
extract what the D and Q are to put
these samplers into our ste framework
but more importantly any valid sampler
you can write down has a D and Q in our
framework so what that means is that
you're exploring the space of all
possible DS and Q's you're exploring the
space of all possible samplers valid
samplers associated you can choose like
you give me any DNA q and I can write
down a pallet sampler seems like this
recipe doesn't include she slides
deterministic Markov processes right so
we're focused on yeah hey wouldn't it
wouldn't be all continuous murder Posse
that have that sure yeah what's the blue
versus the red region what's the
definition of that so the red region are
the is the region where you don't have
the right its modifying the the
distribution here it's no longer
invariant under the specified dynamics
but you I mean ck you have a particular
ste but you have some sort of closure
argument I guess so it is that right and
you're in your theory to say it's all
exactly go to be close to the junk
your site it does not contain the
piecewise she sounds like Jensen mad or
something yes exactly that's exactly
what this statement is saying it's a
yeah oh yeah there's a constructive
proof to show that okay so let's get
into some of the nitty-gritty practical
details of using these types of samplers
one is the fact that of course in
general you can't simulate from the
continuous dynamics so you're going to
consider consider some epsilon
discretization so instead of walking
exactly along here you're going to take
some m little steps of this this
discretization to go from one value to
the next simulated value and so of
course there's some discretization error
recently we've showed that you can
correct for this bias using an
irreversible metropolis Hastings
algorithm that Ian proposed I'm not
going to go through the details here
but what I want to focus on is the fact
that there's this gradient computation
which as we've heard many times today
and is probably pretty obvious is really
computationally intensive for large
status so in particular for each one of
these little steps here you have to make
a pass through your entire data set so
really horribly inefficient for large
data sets okay so these continuous
dynamically samplers are really nice in
terms of efficiency of exploring these
target posteriors but don't scale well
to you very large data sets so let's
think about how we can scale these
gradient based and samtcy procedures and
if you've been awake in a machine
learning literature any time in recent
history the answer should be obvious you
just replace your true gradient or full
data gradient with a stochastic gradient
so we have some mini batch of
observations we're going to have this
correction factor so that for mini
batches sampled uniformly at random this
is going to be an unbiased estimate of
the the true gradient okay well we're
also further going to appeal to the
central limit theorem to assume that the
noise in this gradient is Gaussian and
we need this for the analysis that we're
going to do okay but the high-level
point here is that now we only have to
touch a small amount of our data per
step in this algorithm so I mean if you
you meta showed this application we had
like time series with enormous numbers
of points and you have that for multiple
subjects and so do you sample the times
either this is iid so I'm going to get
back to that when I get to the dependent
part yeah it's a very good point because
every talk and every paper ever written
on this and that's not actually a true
statement but does not state this iid
assumption and I yet I also haven't done
that but I will get back to this idea so
right now we're assuming iid data not
the types of time series that I I talked
about okay so does this work well
there's hope that it would right that's
kind of been the story in the literature
you take your gradient descent method or
your gradient based method you replace a
stochastic gradient and you can prove
things like stochastic gradient descent
you can prove convergence different
rates of course but things work out
pretty nicely and they're practically
really nice and there's also been some
nice stories in the MCMC world max
welling Andy white a propose this
stochastic gradient version of the
Langevin dynamic base sampler so those
are simpler non momentum based dynamics
and there you can show that it's doing
the right thing and of course it's been
well known in the optimization world
that stochastic gradient descent with
momentum can give significantly faster
convergence so a question is what can we
say about momentum based sampling so
what happens to our HMC algorithm when
we replace the gradient with the noisy
gradient okay
well instead of having it just our
standard Hamiltonian dynamics we now
have these noisy Hamiltonian dynamics so
this would be from our stochastic
gradient and so we can think of this as
not playing ice hockey inside by playing
ice hockey outside where there's this
random wind blowing and we're still on
this frictionless ice surface
but this random wind is going to blow
the puck away so a very informal
statement but more formally we can prove
that pi is no longer than fair and
distribution and actually we prove it
but more than that that the entropy of
this distribution increases with time so
things go horribly wrong with this okay
so what can we do so far the story's
pretty negative here well T on she had
this really nice insight of introduce
some friction so instead of playing ice
hockey go play street hockey and so now
there's still this random wind blowing
but you have the friction from the
street surface that's counter balancing
it and very formally it's exactly
counterbalancing the this noise and now
pi is again then variant distribution
under these dynamics okay so um we are
able to define this stochastic gradient
version of HMC through this correction
by adding a friction term to the
dynamics and under certain
specifications of this algorithm you
reduce to SGD with momentum or to this
simpler dynamics of s GLD okay I also
want to mention that in practice you
have this step size that you need to
choose and you need the step size to be
going to zero to get your bias to go to
zero for these algorithms and in
practice we don't warm it do that so we
allow for some bias and just use a
finite Epsilon in practice so you're not
going to eat metropolis correction at
any stage not in what I'm presenting
here I didn't go into that there's a
paper that we have posted and we have
further results on that but we're not
doing we're just like in so scld had the
same assumption of relying on this small
epsilon asymptotics but we're but we're
not so we're doing the same thing here
but it is possible actually as we've
shown to use to introduce a correction
term we people don't know how to do that
before the scales of n seems
with David's algorithms scale it up
because now have these stochastic
gradients right well I'm going to do a
quick compare and contrast that goes
through not the stuff similar kind of
thing so it's a different version well
are you talking about them bearson
really parallel stuff for which I'll go
through a compare and contrast sorry
a lot of I'll get back to that but yeah
so it seems like to do this momentum you
need to know what the variances but
practice you don't really know what the
variance of your yeah so I skipped over
I have some it's details are in the
paper you don't actually need to know
what the variance if you're right
I was hoping people would have noticed
that because I don't have time to go
through it in this talk this assumes you
know what the variance is but we don't
actually assume that in the algorithm
we're proposing yeah so good catch look
at the paper from which details okay or
look at the next slide which does a
little quick change and without telling
you that this should change okay um so
there was this great insight that you
know you add these this friction term to
these Hamiltonian dynamics and great you
get the right thing but what if you're
looking at more complicated dynamics
what's the right correction how do you
show you know what's going on and each
of these things requires a really
detailed proves in a lot of insight into
what you should do to correct the the
noisy dynamics and so what can we do
more generally well the cool thing is we
can just go back to this general recipe
that I presented so this was this D and
Q framework and this was the original
update so this is using the fold data
gradient here and you you can propose a
stochastic gradient Fersen that has
exactly the same properties so here's
our noisy gradient and what you need to
do is you need to subtract off an
estimated the variance of the stochastic
gradient noise so this is a formulation
that skips a couple steps but you don't
actually need to know that you need an
estimate of it though okay and one of
the cool things is if you had gone
through an SG version of HM see in this
framework this friction term at T on Chi
like thought of you know out of nowhere
basically not out of nowhere clearly but
it falls out naturally you wouldn't have
had to have
inside it it just comes from this this
product here okay so going back to the
question of how do you think about
defining desync use open question about
how do you define these and cues that
correspond to efficient things but you
can think about using existing DS and
Q's as building blocks and then doing
different changes on them to get
different properties for new samplers so
let's go through one example here which
is a riemann version of SG h MC and so
it was something that people were
interested in and tried to define for a
while but even if you build off of the
SG h MC approach of having this friction
correction you get the wrong stationary
distribution but instead what we can do
is using this general framework just
take the d and q associated with SG h MC
which i've written down here you can go
back and show that this is true and then
just make them state dependent and then
you get a riemann of this algorithm and
the theory says that it's going to be
doing the right thing and so we applied
this SG r HMC algorithm to streaming Lda
analysis of some Wikipedia articles and
so this is showing perplexity over
iteration so articles explored and what
we see is there's a significant
improvement in performance by going to
the riemann version of these algorithms
that's because mass is concentrating in
this LD a type of example and having the
riemann version really helps in
exploring that but there's still some
benefit in each case going to the
Hamiltonian dynamics instead of these
Langevin dynamics and overall the top
performance is this SGR HMC procedure
that plot doesn't disturb you about the
convergence of your
for either for that matter I guess it
just does it disturb me about
convergence it looks like a toby huss
conversion
oh I mean hell what fitting yeah you
said they have the same stationary
distribution and they're giving
completely different results what has
the same stationary distribution s GLD
right to your LD that's what he just
said oh yeah I mean all should be the
same no I understand no exactly
got it leveled off right because without
the Ramon version it's just still not
very well exploring things so it's you
know you yeah yes oh it's the wrong
stationary distribution um no you'd have
to run it it's not like it's just not
exist yeah yeah you haven't said
anything about the rate of convergence
here trade no and we don't have results
on rates would you observe it's faster
than yeah another example where you had
two Hills on the gap one-dimensional
line or multiple yeah is it probably
faster than yeah so we have lots of
results in the paper versions of these
things showing different simulated
scenarios and things like that and I'll
go through a couple but yes we
definitely have much more thorough
analysis than what I'm going through
here because I wanted to cover dependent
data to will see if I get to that okay
um so very very very quickly because I
do want to get to the dependent data
that was part of the inside here was um
I wanted to do a comparison with what
I'll call these divide and conquer
approaches to paralyzing on CMC or
embarrassingly parallel MCMC and these
are really preliminary results so don't
take too much away from this but point
is if you have some large data set like
David was mentioning you can distribute
these data sub samples across machines
and of course you distribute your prior
as well and then you run MCMC separately
on each of these machines you have to
maintain those samples to form these sub
posteriors and then they get merged
together to form an overall
approximation of your posterior there's
lots of different ways you can form
these sub posteriors and do this merge
step so early on examples were consensus
Monte Carlo which assumes each sub
posterior has a Gaussian form and then
the overall approximation
Gaussian and then nice longer proposed
doing a kernel density estimate per sub
posterior and an MC mc2 to merge these
different estimates to get the
approximate posterior okay so Jack Baker
who's a student joint with Paul fern
head has just done some analyses
comparing these things so one target
distribution we're looking at was a
multivariate t heavy tailed distribution
and so the red curves represent what
we'll use in place of the the target
posterior the exact posterior and the
blue curve is the consensus algorithm
this is the KDE version and this is
stochastic gradient HM C and stochastic
gradient Langevin dynamics and on the
bottom what we're showing is the KL
divergence between those two
distributions for each of these
different algorithms and so you see that
this simple assumption that the
consensus algorithm is making it's not
too bad in this case and we do see that
the momentum from HMC helps explore some
of the tails of this distribution here
if we look at a multi-modal posterior
things are obviously a lot worse for the
consensus algorithm the KDE is doing a
bit better but these SG based methods
are are performing to keep better than
the parallel methods
okay clearly I should have switched to
my new laptop instead of my very dated
one here but um any questions while I'm
I mean the more recent BPM CMC things do
what better yeah that's what I was
saying don't take too much away from
this analysis that we had done this
sucker multimodal
retails yeah okay so um the correlated
target distribution you see the same
type of story
KDE doing you know fairly well but of
course the kernel density estimate is
going to scale really poorly with the
dimensionality of the the target
distribution so the parameter space
whereas the other methods are really
robust to that dimensionality and we
also did an analysis on Lda and because
of the size of the the dictionary here
we didn't even bother looking at KD but
clearly a lot of benefits to looking at
these stochastic gradient methods so yes
I would love to do a comparison to some
of the methods you've been proposing but
this is this were the initial ones that
Jack had done okay so when did I start
okay perfect um so I wanted to talk
about mini batch methods for dependent
data because if you remember from the
beginning my talk I said a lot of the
groups interest is in looking at time
series and there clearly we have
dependent data and like I mentioned
earlier all these stochastic gradient
based methods they never state that
you're really assuming that you have
these iid observations to form these
many batches okay so let's look at this
in the context of a really simple
dynamic model the hmm or there's an
underlying discrete valued state
sequence where condition on that state
sequence your observations are
conditionally independent and we have
some set of global parameters using the
terminology that Dave was using earlier
that represent our transition
probabilities as well as our admission
parameter
they're also arrows here but I'm just
gonna remove those for clarity okay so
let's very quickly review batch learning
for HMS super super quickly
so almost all algorithms whether you're
talking about en base variational based
MCMC based for learning HMMs there tends
to be some underlying forward backward
routine where you propagate information
forward and then you propagate
information backwards in time and then
you combine these two to form your
smooth local state belief so the
probability of being in some state given
the entire sequence of observations and
then you use these local state beliefs
to update your belief about these global
parameters and you iterate back and
forth okay
well the cost of this algorithm is o K
squared T where K is the number of
states and hmm and T is the length of
the time series um and so clearly this
is going to be really really
computationally inefficient when you're
looking at very long time series so for
example one application where we're
faced with this challenge is segmenting
this human chromatin sequence where
there are 250 million locations across
the sequence so having to do a pass
through all 250 million locations per
little update and the parameter space is
pretty infeasible okay so can we just
use these mini-batch based methods that
we've talked about for hidden Markov
models so we could think of just looking
at some little subsequence so some set
of local variables and then doing a
local forward backward pass here and
then using these local state beliefs to
update our global parameters using for
example a stochastic gradient step or
something like that um well the issue
here is that clearly informations
getting blocked right we're not properly
propagating information from our past
and future observations in forming these
local state beliefs okay so if these
represent the true state beliefs as if
we had done the full forward backward
bottom here examples of just what the
approximation might be so question is
are we out of luck
well one thing we can do is leverage the
fact that there's memory decay in this
process so for example do we really
expect that's a state at time T it's
going to strongly influence this data
time T plus a million probably not in
most applications okay so what we can
think about doing is what I'll call
buffering where you do afford backward
on a longer sub chain until locally
within this solid red box you're
approximated local marginals are good
approximations to the true marginals and
then in practice you typically only need
a very limited buffer relative to the
length of the time series you're looking
at to get good approximations and
complexity of course is dramatically
reduce per iteration and similar ideas
were proposed in this splash BP paper
for paralyzing belief propagation but
they're they assumed a fixed parameter
setting where as here we have this
uncertain parameter setting so in
particular our buffer size depends on
our current belief about theta so we're
going to take theta do this local
procedure then update theta and do this
iteratively okay because that encodes
basically the memory of the process
right so if you have if you initialize
to some theta that says it's a super
long memory process you're going to need
very long buffers and yeah
hey [ __ ] that you said before when
you're making an update since it's a
sill right
can you just compute the special cap and
just yes so I'll get back to that for
it's a little bit yeah I'll get back to
an idea for the MC MC approach if that's
okay
but yeah I mean you can look at the
second largest eigen value of the major
the transition matrix and do things like
this so in this case it was a little
more complicated for reasons I can
discuss offline if that's okay so we
looked at this idea in the context of
stochastic variational inference and I'm
not going to talk about the algorithm
but you can imagine based on Dave's talk
how you can think about using these
ideas in that context and you can prove
that if you're within some epsilon
approximation of the true marginals then
the algorithm converges to a local mode
of objective just like in the batch case
but we use it to segment this human
chromatin sequence where the previous
analysis used a dynamic Bayesian network
so a more complicated dynamic Bayesian
network and because of complexity of
inference in that model had to break
this sequence into little chunks and
analyze each separately whereas we used
or very vanilla hmm
Gaussian emissions and applied this svi
procedure to it and we actually ended up
with lower false discovery rate of
promoter regions well let's just say
competitive performance but here this
algorithm was highly optimized
distributed across machines and took
days to run and ours finished in under
an hour
okay but the point of this talk was
talking about MCMC so let's think about
whether you can use these mini batch
based methods in the context of hg MCMC
so why is the talk not over and if a
couple more minutes to explain why
there's still a story here
one of the challenges is the fact that
SG MC MC assumes that you have a
continuous parameter space that you're
sampling and all the algorithms that
we've talked about for HMMs are doing
these operations on these discrete
valued latent state sequences the other
thing is that in the MCMC world you have
to be very careful when you're thinking
about
being that you have the correct
stationary distribution things are a
little bit more finicky than an
optimization where you can just say
you're noisy gradient is close enough to
your true gradient so you have to think
about this in the context of this finite
buffering and the fact that our
subsequence is that we're using within a
mini batch are correlated with one
another other limitations to spi hmm is
of course it's a variational approach so
it's really targeting an approximation
to the posterior we were assuming
conjugate priors of course you could do
some of the fancier newer things instead
of that and we also use this heuristic
buffer length estimation procedure but
here we're going to propose something
that's more formal so we're going to try
and avoid these assumptions here okay so
the first challenge is the fact that we
want to get to this continuous parameter
representation so what we're going to
propose is simply to marginalize the
latent state sequence and what this
picture is kind of poorly trying to
represent is that everything gets
connected when you do that but the local
correlations if you're focusing in just
on a region vary the observations are
more correlated locally than they are
far away so you still have this memory
decay to this process okay but let's
write down this marginal likelihood
explicitly and here pi is just PI 0 it's
just the probability of being in any
state add initially and these big P
matrices so as our transition matrix and
these big P matrices are just the likely
a term so likelihood of observation YT
given some state assignment represented
as a diagonal matrix so this overall big
matrix vector multiply is doing just a
forward pass or backward pass of the
forward backward algorithm to compute
the marginal likelihood okay well it's
going to be useful to rewrite this in
terms of focusing in on one little
subsequence so in particular I've just
expanded all the terms in this marginal
likelihood calculation and I'm going to
group together all the terms
corresponding to these observations and
likewise all the observations here and
observations here so these observations
if I just do
this product up to this point represents
this forward message of probability of
being in some state given the history of
observations and likewise on the right
hand side is the backward message so
probability of future observations given
a state assignment okay um so this is
just a rewriting or marginal likelihood
and what we can do then is we can pass
this into our gradient based MCMC step
where we have to compute this would
remember that our potential energy is
just log likelihood times log prior or
plus log prior and so this is our our
likelihood plug it in compute the
partial with respect to some parameter
of interest and if we compute that
partial you end up with this really
nasty thing and I'll break down why it's
so nasty basically because of the
product rule here and if you expand out
all these terms this partial it's going
to end up touching everything and so you
can rewrite it in a lot of ways but one
that's really convenient is summing over
a set of disjoint sub sequences and let
me just rewrite this here so the
gradient that we need in our MCMC
procedure has a sum over all disjoint
sub sequences and worse than that there
are these Q and PI operations where for
each one of these sub sequences we have
to do this for backward thing we have
these messages coming in okay so this is
pretty doubly hideous but what we can
think about doing again is taking a
stochastic gradient approach where in
the simplest case you would just look at
one of these little sub sequences in
that sum but you still have these q and
pi calculations so remember what these
are and a question like we asked before
is if we're looking at the probability
of being in a state at time I does that
really depend on the entire history of
observations probably not so we can
think about approximating these again
using the same types of buffering ideas
we talked about before where this is
in the form of these we just look at the
likelihood terms in the buffer regions
and ignore all the observations outside
those buffer regions and use that as an
approximation okay so a question is how
much buffering is sufficient and here
what we're going to propose doing is
estimating the buffer length by
estimating the Lyapunov exponent of the
underlying random dynamical system and
so for given error tolerance that you
might specify we can then tell you how
long of a buffer that you need okay and
so if you think of mini-batches you
think of collections of observations
here are mini-batch we're going to think
of as collections of sub sequences so
this what I've talked about is just one
sub sequence but we might want to
introduce collections of sub sequences
to improve the efficiency of the
stochastic gradient method but these sub
sequences are correlated with one
another so what we're going to do is
we're going to enforce a minimum gap nu
which is also in this case it's
estimated based off of this is going
back to what Ryan was saying before the
spectral gap there okay so what this
allows us to do jointly now that we have
these approximately independent little
mini batches that have approximately the
right gradient computation is we can
appeal to the central limit theorem as
we did before and plug this into our SEM
CNC theory and show that in the case of
hmms where we're getting at the right
thing okay so I'll just wrap up with a
really very quick analysis of some ion
channel data where this data was studied
previously by in these papers that were
developing Bayesian nonparametric
dynamical models and because of
complexity of inference in those models
they looked at either 2000 or 10,000
observations whereas we're looking at
over 200,000 observations and what these
plots this plot is showing is this is
observations over time colored by
inferred state and this is using a batch
gradient based MCMC method this is after
700
seconds mm seconds 7,000 seconds doesn't
look like it's changing much so you
might say okay it's converged and I'm
going to produce this as my segmentation
but if you use the SG version of that
algorithm then this is after just 44
seconds looks pretty similar to what
you're getting after 7,000 seconds here
130 seconds four hundred sixty seconds
qualitatively different here and so much
more rapidly you can actually show what
the converge solution here looks like so
if you run this out forever and ever you
eventually get to things that look like
this so this is a plot showing this I
won't go through the details this is log
log scale so you really see the
difference in the scalability of these
approaches okay so to wrap up we
presented this general recipe for
devising these continuous dynamic based
samplers defined just by these two
matrices and we talked about stochastic
gradient versions of those algorithms
both for independent data as well as
dependent data sources focusing in on
HMMs and talking about this idea of
buffering that leverages the memory
decay of the process and of course the
marginal likelihood representation was
really key for these SG MCMC methods
okay thank you any questions questions
is there any way to tell how much you're
like losing I mean you were focusing on
this kind of machine learning
what output I mean if you're if you're
running this kind of funding that we
have these neuroscience studies a bunch
of animals and you want to see what's
different and brain networks across
groups and you have you know tens of
millions of time points he did this
little mini batching and the scientists
wanted to know like how far off are you
what are you losing for doing that what
you so what is the air that were
introducing in our yeah how much
information are you losing about things
you care about like we have just like
you have theoretical analyses we have
theoretical analyses of the correctness
of these algorithms but of course in
practice their choices that you make
just like that the asymptotics in your
results don't kick in right when you're
dealing with your neuroscience data so
they're gonna converge to whatever the
right things yeah yeah yeah we have all
that no no it's not about it's I mean is
okay I'm failing to see the difference
here because MCMC again it's run it
forever right and you as you're running
it you have the right stationary
distribution our correctness is not
about how long you're running it our
correctness is about letting epsilonc go
to zero okay let's go so practically
what do you lose how much your
information vary so that the loss is not
setting Epsilon choosing letting epsilon
go to zero right that's that's the only
place where that approximation kicks in
there you have like 50 million time
points you have to opt out so
practically if you're running it you
can't be putting too much data in and so
have you done cleanliness where you kind
of increase the number of many batches
or the sizes yes so like in these
experiments are many batches are
sometimes only five observations we're
putting in per iteration and so I'm
trying to understand because you're
saying I guess like there's an
approximation error that's was it was
size five then your I think we have
practical approximation error maybe if
you did some limit you don't have any
approximation error but your practical
approximation error okay again you're
getting to the practical you're getting
to the practical question right which is
I could ask you the same question for
your wasp out for them right so um yeah
so the press no exactly no sure I guess
what I'm just saying is we're all in
say does your algorithm okay um sorry I
guess what I'm saying is that it seemed
like in your talk you're kind of saying
they're approximations for these SG
based methods and ours don't ours do the
right thing and I'm just saying that of
course we're all relying on asymptotics
and cutting a general family of
algorithm and I guess that's my in our
setting which is a little different than
yours you tend to need a pretty big
batch size or your approximation error
with water right and so what we're
talking about so the practical practical
thing is about the variance of the
stochastic gradient our examples I'm
just trying to I'm not so criticize you
at all okay so I guess then let's say
the practical issues so the practical
issues are the variance of the
stochastic gradient noise like in all
these cases and actually Jack has some
results on using control theory it's to
reduce that but that's one thing and
there are theoretical results and the
simpler dynamic cases like the Langevin
dynamics on how you think about what
that error is but yeah in practice
that's why I was saying here's the
picture you don't just choose one little
subsequence you choose a whole bunch but
remember that your so okay so in things
that have very long memories this can be
really efficient because if you look at
a mini batch of length 100 you might be
getting just one little part of what's
happening in the time series but if we
look at ten minutes of size 10 that are
distributed across the time series in
practice you get much more efficiency
because you're exploring different parts
of what's going on in the process so it
has to do the trade-offs and we explore
this in the paper but the trade-offs
between how many observations you choose
versus how many how many observations
per subsequence versus how many mini
batches have to do with properties of
the underlying dynamical process of
course um and of course they're the same
kind of results as all these stochastic
gradient methods that as you're
increasing the number of observations
you know you're reducing your variance
and getting better performance along so
same kind of ideas they're um trying to
think if there's another part that
missed from what you're saying but your
question was how many observations do
you think you need to put in in these
neuroscience applications per iteration
is that what you're okay
sorry if I miss the point there for
these continuous bass samplers physical
these continuous
sadly that the only thing that will
change the stationary distribution
it's that yeah alright so I'm a little
confused about of why
I mean essentially it sounds like you're
saying that anything will work if we
don't add an external force create some
sort of external as long as you have a
detailed balanced image that you're
going to say so actually I should say
that these are not reversible processes
that we're defining so but what I mean
so detailed balance is sufficient but
not necessary right and so these are not
satisfying that and same with the
irreversible metropolis Hastings sampler
that we proposed that also breaks that
by definition of being irreversible and
so let me understand more about what
you're saying
well so I guess it seems to me like
you're saying you can you know oppose
these various like diffusion tensors
right and you're suggesting differential
equation and that they don't affect the
variant distribution which you know
that's I mean from the perspective of
having a Hamiltonian dynamics that's
that's obvious right right all right
even the dynamics we're not changing
right the distribution right but that's
not obvious for I can write down lots of
dynamics for example like the SG HMC
dynamic is doesn't have the right
invariant distribution right so I can
write down lots of examples of dynamics
change the age
but adding external force right right
but what I'm saying is you can specify
an H of course you can't specify an H
and different DS and Q's and get things
wrong because our framework that that is
our framework but you could specify an H
you don't have to go to the stochastic
version you can specify an H and
different pre multipliers of that H in
different forms for the noise and get
wrong and variant distributions or
things that like the target is no longer
invariant so it's only under this
specific form of the SD and it doesn't
have to be an SD you can have that noise
term go to zero so it can be an OD e but
under that those are all the cases where
pi is invariant and I can write down
cases that aren't in the framework and
then that doesn't have the right
invariant distribution yeah think about
what what advantages
Fifty's and Q's I mean essentially I
think like the Riemann one was an
example so going back to I won't flip
all the way back but the LDA example
like without that riemann thing those
samplers still weren't doing great they
still weren't exploring the posterior
very well because mask it's like really
concentrated in the landscape so that
you more easily you need the geometry of
the space to really help you get between
those points yeah okay so I see you
tomorrow